what's going on guys in this video i'll
be breaking down the 13th opening for
black clover which is being used for the
spade kingdom arc which is now started
in the anime
we'll be talking about the visuals and
the significance of certain moments
but regarding the actual song itself
this was a song called grandeur and it
was very upbeat
which is not something you'd typically
expect from an arc like this
however it does work really well when
paired with the visuals
i do prefer it to the previous two songs
that we had for openings 11 and 12
but you know i still like those ones as
well i just think this one is better
than those
before we get into the breakdown there
will be big spoilers in this video
because
the opening itself contains many
references to spoilers and it'll just be
impossible to talk about it properly
without going into it
if you're an anime only watcher for
black clover and you don't read the
manga
then i 100 recommend that you stop
watching this video
but be sure to subscribe because there
will be more non-spoilery videos
coming on this channel for the spay
kingdom arc with that said
let's get into it and first place to
start is the is the beginning
with astor walking through the strange
hallway with candles surrounding him
this scene had a strong red aura and
this shade of red is the same color we
see whenever aston's devil appears
the only occasion in the manga where
candles were surrounding asta on the
ground like this was when he was about
to perform the devil binding ritual
to properly gain control over his devil
and you know harness the power of his
anti-magic abilities
this opening scene is a reference to
that ritual and therefore it makes sense
that the red aura of the devil should be
illuminating the scene
additionally this moment is also a
parallel to black clover's first ever
opening
where we saw a younger aster walking in
the same way before the scene pauses on
his face
and has this black and white type of
effect and the same effect can be seen
in the 13th opening
which is obviously an intentional
mirroring of the first one so
it's kind of meant to show us how much
he's grown in the 157 episode since we
first saw
the original opening things then move
over to asta flying through the sky on
his demon slayer sword
as funeral watches on in amazement from
the ground this is a throwback to
chapter 232
when finro couldn't help but admire
astor's progress from someone who had no
magic and couldn't even fly on a broom
to what he is today we then got a few
character shots featuring those who were
training in the heart kingdom
before switching over to yuno who stands
atop of the golden dawn staircase
we've seen in the past how typically
only the captain or vice captain of the
golden dawn will stand on top of this
staircase
and during the filler for those who
missed it yuna was promoted to a first
class senior magic knight
with the old vice captain longress
having now left the golden dawn for the
time being at least
yuno is therefore the new vice captain
which is why he's standing where he is
after this we get a brief shot of a
mysterious woman and for any anime
owners who didn't listen to my previous
spoiler warning
pause the video now and do not go any
further as manga readers will know
this moment is a flashback to the past
in which ass's mother was about to die
and it's immediately followed by a one
second clip of a devil possessed aster
just going berserk
the rage in this moment isn't just
astor's rage but it's also the anger of
the devil inside him
because we now know that astor's devil
did have a mother-son relationship
with astor's mother as weird as that
sounds i mean they're basically step
brothers
this scene is interspersed with a
glimpse of yuno's mother and a flashback
image of xenon from the dark triad
during the night in which the dark triad
killed the spade kingdom royal family
even though in the anime he doesn't know
it yet this is the moment that changed
juno's life because
without this attack you know probably
would have been the prince of the spay
kingdom by now
who knows he might have even been the
king of the spade kingdom if his father
had died
so it's just interesting to see this
scene here we then briefly see a present
day you know screaming in anguish
which was a scene directly from the
manga after the golden dawn
had been totally wrecked by xenon
speaking of the dark triad
they immediately appear after this
moment and it was really interesting to
see xenon's facial expression here
as he appears genuinely shocked by
something he's still smiling so whatever
he's discovered is you know
is information that still makes him
happy but there's two possibilities that
i see
the most likely possibility is that
xenon's expression
is referring to the time when he faced
off against yuno at the golden dawn
headquarters
and i say that because it's the only
moment in the series in which xenon has
genuinely smiled
on the other hand this could be
referencing something that might be
revealed in the future
that even manga readers haven't seen yet
because i wouldn't rule it out i mean
this opening
already reveals some things quite far
into the spade kingdom arc
so who knows maybe there's something
else that will make xenon smile like
this
it was interesting to see lucifero get
his own individual moment in this
opening
because based on everything we know so
far he is the strongest devil and the
true villain of this arc
the way i see it dante and the rest of
the dark triad are simply
vessels that the devils are using to
fulfill their goal of entering the human
world
if lucifero is successful in his plan
then i don't think he'd have much need
for the dark triad after that's done
astor is then seen fighting against some
random spay kingdom people
before the opening gives us the real
thing we've been waiting for which is a
preview of the three main fights from
the beginning of this arc
universe's xenon looks like it's going
to be great and i love the way that you
know spirit dive is animated in this
brief moment
noel versus vanika also got some screen
time as well as the first ever anime
look
at her mermaid form valkyrie armor
aesthetically it looks a lot better for
various reasons
but that's just my opinion the final
fight was a preview of yammy vs dante
and as you can see yami is in the
position to do his
death thrust spell which absolutely blew
everyone's minds when it was first shown
in the manga
so i can't wait to see how the fandom
reacts to this being an animated form
we can see dante in the background with
his 80 devil form
and uh yeah that's all there is to say
for now but obviously as the anime
progresses we'll see the form in its
entirety
as the opening comes to a close we get a
good look at the tree of clipboth
i think that's how you say it and this
will connect the underworld to the human
world and allow the devils to cross over
the heart kingdom queen then falls down
in the same manner as he did
in the cover for volume 26 and then
surprisingly
our boy knocked makes an appearance i
honestly wasn't expecting him to make a
significant appearance in this opening
but you know there he is with his shadow
magic and judging by the ground i'm
pretty sure
that this is the moment when he first
approached asta i feel like this opening
has an unusual amount of spoilers
especially if you compare it to the uh i
don't know the last few openings for
black clover
this one definitely has way more
spoilers in it than usual
there's then this epic shot of astor's
arm transforming into the devil arm that
he currently has
and i love the way his arm just breaks
apart and then is transformed into this
new thing
but if you forgot this was part of an
exchange that aston made with his devil
to gain the power he needed during an
emergency
i thought the opening was going to end
with this shot of aston yami
but surprisingly it continued on to
literally show us aston's devil in his
true form
and then another blurry glimpse of
astor's mother what do you guys think do
you agree with me like were there
too many spoilers in this opening or do
you think that anime only viewers won't
really understand it because there's not
enough context
whatever you think let me know down
below and don't forget to sub as i will
be doing more black clothing videos
as the spade kingdom arc continues i'd
appreciate if you dropped a like if you
liked this video
and until the next one peace out